[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france24 esta semana dedicamos el
programa al acuerdo de escazú el primer
tratado regional en materia ambiental de
américa latina y el caribe y el primero
en el mundo que incluye disposiciones
específicas sobre los defensores
ambientales es un acuerdo que tiene como
objetivo garantizar la implementación
total y efectiva de los derechos de
acceso a la información ambiental de
participación pública en los procesos de
toma de decisiones y de acceso a la
justicia en asuntos ambientales además
busca la cooperación internacional para
proteger el derecho a vivir en un medio
ambiente saludable sin embargo dos años
después de su creación aún no ha sido
ratificado el 26 de septiembre de este
año se cumplía el plazo para que de los
24 países firmantes del acuerdo al menos
11 lo ratificarán para que así pudiera
entrar en vigor pero hasta la fecha sólo
10 lo han hecho curiosamente a pesar de
que las negociaciones fueron lideradas
por chile y costa rica ninguno de estos
dos países lo ha ratificado
chile ni siquiera lo ha firmado algo que
pone en entredicho el compromiso del
país en materia ambiental país que
recordemos actualmente tiene la
presidencia de la cumbre sobre cambio
climático de la onu las razones del
gobierno son que el texto que ellos
mismos ayudaron a redactar es demasiado
ambiguo y que daría pie a posibles
demandas internacionales
el problema del caso está en la forma en
que quedó escrito el texto final la
ambigüedad y amplitud en que quedaron
redactados algunos de sus artículos
sumado al carácter supra legal de este
tratado es decir que se aplica por sobre
toda la legislación nacional así como el
hecho de que no permita hacer ningún
tipo de reservas genera una gran
incertidumbre jurídica en cuanto a la
legislación interna aplicar en nuestro
país que en definitiva el acuerdo expone
al país a la contingencia de demandas
internacionales por razones ambientales
lo que desde nuestro punto
y particularmente considerando los
términos de este tratado implica una
afectación grave es soberanía en
materias que son fundamentales para el
desarrollo le pregunté a paulina astroza
doctora en ciencias políticas y sociales
de la universidad de concepción en chile
si realmente estos argumentos están
justificados y ella apuntaba más bien a
que podría haber intereses económicos
detrás de la negativa del gobierno a
firmar el acuerdo de escazú tanto los
argumentos que el gobierno de chile dio
en 2018 para no firmar como el informe
jurídico que se acaba de presentar
después de dos años en los cuales nos
presenta el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores el ministerio de medio
ambiente yo no encuentro ninguna razón
jurídica desde el punto de vista del
derecho internacional tampoco del punto
de vista de relaciones internacionales y
colegas míos han analizado el punto de
vista del derecho ambiental y la
legislación interna tampoco
razones válidas para no firmar entonces
entramos en el terreno de la
especulación y por algunas afirmaciones
que se han hecho creo que por un lado
hay un miedo a la judicialización de los
temas en materia ambiental
lo que también es rebatible porque si
hay mayor participación si hay mayor
transparencia si antes de que sean
aprobados los proyectos ambientales es
la ciudadanía quién puede participar
evidentemente eso te ayuda a que previo
a llegar a los tribunales pudieran
llegarse a soluciones y no lo contrario
y por otro lado también yo creo que hay
un sector importante fuerte en chile que
piensa que a través de la aprobación del
acuerdo a esta suya esta mayor
participación ciudadana transparencia
acceso a la justicia y mayor democracia
en definitiva en materia ambiental bueno
sus proyectos de inversión son negocios
en algunos sectores particulares
pudieran verse en riesgo justamente por
ésta por lo que establece el acuerdo de
escazú porque yo creo que va por ahí
las razones fundamentales y no los
argumentos jurídicos que se plantearon
los cuales son todos absolutamente
rebatibles
el tratado sigue abierto a que los
países que aún no lo han firmado
ratificado se adhieran pero habrá que
esperar a esa undécima firma para que
entre en vigor una espera que para
amnistía internacional muestra una falta
de interés por parte de los gobiernos de
la región una región que es la más
mortífera del mundo para los defensores
ambientales
pese a que la entrada en vigor del
acuerdo de descanso podría ser un avance
substancial en la política de los
estados de la región frente a la
emergencia climática y la crisis de
violencia en contra de personas
defensoras del medio ambiente la
lentitud de algunos estados para
ratificarlo demuestra el desinterés que
aún existe en varios países en la región
de tomar medidas para construir una
política ambiental más participativa
accesible y justa
precisamente la coordinadora de
organizaciones indígenas de la cuenca
amazónica solicitó a la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos que
llame la atención a los gobiernos de
perú bolivia colombia ecuador y brasil
ante los asesinatos amenazas y
violaciones de derechos humanos a las
que estas comunidades se enfrentan todos
los días y solicitó que el aceite h
interceda para que los gobiernos
amazónicos tomen medidas efectivas de
protección es todo por estas semanas
sigan con más medioambiente en france 24
punto com
[Música]